foreign
to the addiction of pornography and
masturbation and I became super heavily
addicted and I still am was like
masturbating like 30 times a day and
it's really bad and I don't laugh when I
say it to me it's not a laughing matter
it's hell it's hell
[Music]
yo yo yo what's up this is John with the
Dr John deloney show so glad you joined
us
on the most extraordinary mental health
marriage parenting podcast that's ever
existed I'm running in here hot man
dropping my keys let's get this thing
going I'm excited glad you're here if
you want to be on this show show we walk
alongside real people struggling with
real things and we just figure out hey
what what what what's the next right
step what are we gonna do
um and I do say we collectively because
so many of these challenges that we face
that we think it's my mental health
issue it's my diagnosis or it's my
addiction man
Neuroscience keeps figuring out what
we've known collectively for thousands
of years which is that we're all in this
together and if my neighbors struggling
that I'm struggling and if I'm winning
and my next door neighbors not winning
I'm not winning and if I win a fight
with my wife we both lose and so we're
all in this together and so it's an
honor and a blessing to walk alongside
you
um and I'm grateful for your trust if
you want to be on the show give me a
buzz
1-844-693-3291 please take 0.2 seconds
hit the Subscribe button just hit it
um and you really help spin this sucker
up into the algorithms and help other
people who've never heard of the show
um get a hold of it and leave your five
star reviews if you've got two star
reviews
um send them to Jenna she loves them
um she has an oversized self-esteem and
this helps just level the world a little
bit do not send them to Kelly because
she'll get in her car and come burn your
house down all right let's go to Joseph
in Las Vegas what's up Joseph
hey Dr John how you doing good my
brother what are you doing man
uh nothing much man just started college
about a month ago
um kind of getting my life together if
that's the best way to describe it hey
if you if you if you figure out how to
get your life together in your first
semester of college you were way ahead
of the game man I didn't know what day
it was until like my junior year good
for you dude that's funny yeah I'm
trying to get my life together as of
right now it hasn't really been easy
I'll just say that you know tell me
about it tell me about it yeah well I
I've got some issues going on and I I
think that they need to really be
addressed because this is really
stealing my life and it's really
stealing my hopes for the future and and
I don't I I think if this isn't this
problem isn't addressed with me
I really I I really think I'm gonna have
a hard time making it through adult life
and trying to
become a man because you know how old
are you the way I'm going oh I just
turned 18 about a month ago okay I don't
I don't know what you're about to tell
me
but I don't want you to give up on
yourself right now
okay I want to start this conversation
with a sense of optimism not a sense of
if I don't it's all over because you're
18 man okay
yeah is that cool
yeah I understand what you're saying I
hear you and I also know that whatever
you're working through right now feels
like it's weighing you down so let's get
into it man what what's going on in your
life yeah so ever since elementary
school I've always had this struggle
talking to women and you know it and I
feel like none of them have ever liked
me it's like if any ever did try to talk
to me
I feel like it was just you know to um
to just to I would say not to I would
always say brush me on but like to kind
of just play with me like funny kind of
to make fun of me if that's a better
word to use and I struggled with this
all through elementary school and all
through middle school and pretty much
all through high school I see other guys
who you know who are you know who who I
wouldn't say they had girlfriends I mean
I'd say they were much better than me
and they they were they had the
opportunity
have a better social life to hang out
and I I feel like you know I and then
this is might sound typical to most
people but to me it's a big struggle and
I'll tell you why because it led me down
a passive addiction that I I I really
I I really wish I would have never
started I'd say that it's it's like a
cigarette and I got into the addiction
of pornography and masturbation and I
became super heavily addicted and I
still am was like masturbating like 30
times a day and it's really bad and I
don't laugh when I say it because it to
me it's not a laughing matter no it's
hell dude it's hell it's hell it's like
a cigarette it's way worse than a
cigarette it's way worse than a
cigarette man okay you don't have to
justify it to me it's uh 30 times like
yeah you're a full-blown addict man and
that's hell
um
yeah so I'm not laughing at all with you
okay yeah and so yeah thank you John and
then so it was and then what's worse
about it is that I I feel I I feel lost
I I feel angry I feel
I feel lonely and then my mom didn't
allow me to get my driver's license till
I was
18 which was this last year and so when
I would see all these people that had a
much better I would say life and I was
had no job I had no uh I had no car I I
really really felt miserable like I felt
really really
miserable and depressed and what's worse
even worse is that even till now when I
have all the opportunity to pick up more
work and to you know control my finances
and control
I I feel like that scar of the last
eight years of my life
sticks with me because it's kind of like
I got out of high school and I'm like
I wouldn't say what now but I'd say more
like you know
like it's it's just a big ball of
confusion and then dealing with this
addiction it's it's it's just I feel
like that's what's made it hard to move
out and you know not move out but uh
move on
from it and try to get away from it and
it this pornography addiction led me
down
severe it led me down a really really
severe path of insanity not only in my
addiction but in my mental health and in
the way I view things and the way I
spend money and in the way I've I so far
because of my addiction I've lost over
I'd say about three thousand dollars in
shavings that I was supposed to use for
adulthood I spent it on uh
spent it on supporting my addiction
supporting my laziness supporting all of
this and so it it just really has not
been good and it and I want to be honest
with you John because you're a doctor
and you know you're you're a therapist
it led me down uh
very hard it led me down a path of a
different type of pornography that is
not that is not who I am
that the I did that type of pornography
just
because I was so desperate and felt very
alone and I still do feel very alone
till this day
like it feels like every day is a good
Friday to me you know and and I tried to
go see a therapist and you know usually
therapists are supposed to help you but
I felt like this guy
reasoned more with what I was doing
then recognizing that it was a problem
and helping me switch So eventually I
stopped going I mean he was a nice guy
but I really didn't feel like that was
like he was helping much and I was okay
okay hold on
stop stop okay I got I got the gist of
it
um
are you involved in child pornography
um no
um it's a diff uh if you want I can tell
you which type yeah
um well I started with straight
pornography but then I would go on this
uh video cam website and I would
masturbate with other men okay
yeah and that was the type that I was
doing and it goes completely against my
values as you know as a Catholic as a
Christian it goes completely against my
values as a man as a as a Christian as
as a person who goes and participates in
the Eucharist every week it feels wrong
okay okay okay okay okay okay
yeah all right
um
do me a huge favor
yes take a deeper breath as humanly
possible that you could the biggest
breath you can feel in your lungs and
hold it for five seconds a count of five
one two three
four
blow it out as hard as you can
okay
now
thank you for being brave and for saying
stuff out loud that you've probably
never said out loud before
never what you've just done is hard okay
and you're gonna feel particularly
vulnerable and particularly exposed as
though you were Buck Naked you just
threw the windows open
um in front of a group a huge group of
people okay
I want you to sit in that discomfort for
a second because you're also going to
find that's where the healing starts
okay
yeah right now
your mom ran a pretty tight ship didn't
she
yeah
and you were
a trophy correct
correct and she shined the trophy up
to make sure everybody in her world
could see how shiny you were right
correct and she protected you from
yourself because you weren't to be
trusted right
I'm sorry that you were
set off
on that Adventure because you were a kid
and you instead of being taught how to
trust yourself and that you were lovely
and worth being loved and that what you
felt and thought mattered you were told
you're gross you have issues that only I
can solve for you
and suddenly what emerged from that that
soil that she created for you
is a guy that doesn't like himself and
it looks at every other person who
interacts with him as you've created
stories and put them in other people's
heads and actions that they are acting
towards you in a certain way because
they're having fun at your expense
That's how little you think of yourself
Fair correct I'd say that's Joseph you
don't suck you're not a loser
okay
cool
absolutely
in it I'm sitting here pretty fired up
that your mom never told you that where
was your where was your old man doing
all this
so we have a kind of a crazy family
story we almost lost our house in 2008
2009 my mom had over a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars in credit card
debt that she eventually paid off it
took about us about seven years to get
done I know but where's your dad
my dad was working him most of the time
you know becoming gazelle intense so I
didn't really have him that much in my
life at a very young age he didn't
really come in much until about I was
about 11 or 12 or really I wouldn't say
until I was about 13 14. okay so he was
absent for some of the most important
moments of your life
correct
No hugs from Dad no dad doing bad times
no dad grabbing you by the face and
saying hey by the way I won the cosmic
Lottery getting you as my son none of
that
none of that it was it was a very tough
period
okay
so here's what I want to tell you
we'll get to the negativity part
because you are um destroying yourself
and you know that so I'm not going to be
like your former therapist and try to
talk you into making peace with yourself
you have a behavior that you want to
change I'm here for you okay exactly but
how we ended up here is very common and
very normal
that's how I can hear two sentences
about how what your mom said and peel
back the entire story because I've heard
it ten thousand times okay correct so
let me ask you what does pornography
bring you
it honestly it brings me temporary
pleasure but it doesn't bring me
fulfillment hey don't try to take don't
take the back end of it off what does
pornography get you
it brings me uh satisfaction brings me
uh
it brings me a sense of of love it kind
of fulfills what a girlfriend is
supposed to do but since I can't get
that I I use this nope nope nope nope
see here's where you're wrong okay I
want to change all that right now
it isn't substituting for what a
girlfriend would bring you that's a
false narrative
what it does is it makes you feel like
you think you would feel if you had a
girlfriend this is about you not some
external person
yeah I understand that it makes you feel
like finally
this is what it would feel like to be
loved to be intimate with somebody
that's exactly what I feel yeah and then
you end up with a bunch of people in a
live webcam actually telling you
you're beautiful keep doing this you are
bringing me pleasure and you think that
you don't have that ability and so you
like that feeling even though you don't
like where you are and what you're doing
correct that's very true fair oh it's
very true you hit it spot on okay
here's why that's important because you
have to identify what pornography brings
you
because we're going to meet those needs
elsewhere okay
not going out and finding sex because
this isn't about sex this is about a kid
who hates himself
correct and hates the world that has
been created for him and I say that
intentionally because just until
recently you were a child
okay and I know you've been 16-17 having
no dad you've had to grow up quick
having a mom who went off the rails
um you had to grow up quick but you were
a child okay
yeah and so
here's what we're going to do to walk
out of this thing okay
and
um today's first conversation is a huge
start okay
absolutely
number one I'm going to give you uh one
two three four I'm gonna give you five
things okay
and here's what I'm gonna do because I
know this is torturing you right now
we're gonna clip this call and it won't
the show won't come out for you know a
month or so I'm gonna clip this call and
send it to you today or tomorrow okay
unedited all right because I want you to
have these five things and I want you to
play on Loop you are not a bad kid
got it
absolutely none of this hap there is no
healing here
if you keep telling Joseph that Joseph
sucks
that's like looking at a wound that a
surgeon's just stitched up and you cut
it open again and you cut it open again
we have to start from a place of
Joseph's a kid that went through a lot
of nonsense and then found himself over
his head as a child and now as an adult
he's trying to dig himself out okay
that's a totally different proposition
then I got about 24 months left and I'm
eternally ruined
because that's not true okay it's not
true and this is a I'm in my 40s dude
I'm double double your life right yeah
I've had multiple ups and downs over my
heads what do I do now right and there's
light at the end of almost every tunnel
all right so here's what we're gonna do
first and this is an exercise between
you and probably a counselor
or somebody you trust who's an older
probably an older man
but here's the question we're going to
ask ourselves who are we going to become
okay right now you're trying to quit
porn
and you can White Knuckle it and you can
scratch and Claw and get 24 hours and
get 48 hours and get 72 hours and then
you're right back in it
because your energy is focused on not
doing a thing
okay
instead I want you to think who am I
gonna become
who do I want to be what kind of adult
do I want to be I'm not going to be that
kind of dad who disappears on his kid
for a decade I'm not gonna be that kind
of mom who imprisons her children and
says it's for their own good right I'm
I'm gonna become this and then we're
going to start reverse engineering
behaviors that help us become that I'm a
guy that stewards his body
that means I exercise that means I I
don't eat the cereal bar in the
cafeteria every single morning and I
don't grab ice cream every time I walk
out even though it's unlimited I Love
College cafeterias
and I'm gonna use the gym
a couple of times a week and I'm not
going to masturbate 30 times a day
you see what I'm saying like this is all
wrapped up in I'm a guy that takes care
of his body I'm a guy that takes care of
his mind okay second thing is we're
gonna trigger we're gonna identify
triggers trigger identification what
makes what sets you off
looking at hot attractive girls on
Instagram okay then Instagram is deleted
30 seconds after this phone call is over
got it yeah because you are choosing to
enter into a fantasy
that you can't control this is you not
going to bars anymore
because you're an alcoholic right this
is you taking all the booze in your
house and pouring it down the sink
because you're an alcoholic
you're going to delete all of the apps
all everything off your phone and if you
got to go to a flip phone just for six
months go to a flip phone for six months
got it correct okay that leads me to
number three hurdles in roadblocks you
have to intentionally put things in
front of you that make access to your
addiction hard make it challenging and
by the way I also don't believe you
fully yes seeing hot girls on Instagram
cool that lights your brain up like a
Christmas tree awesome but I'm willing
to bet that when you feel rejected
or you feel exhausted but you can't
sleep when you feel wound up on the
inside out when your body feels anxious
masturbation is a release Fair
it is okay yes whenever you start
feeling like I suck I don't like my
major I don't know what I'm doing mom's
calling and Dad's texting
you can go to another Universe where you
are a completely different guy that you
can Captivate 15 men around a cam a
webcam you can Captivate Captivate three
women
who are imaginary you see what I'm
saying exactly it's when you feel
powerless so yes looking at pretty women
uh you're on a college campus for God's
sake dude there's gonna be beautiful
women everywhere
it's more than that it's when you feel
less than
exactly here's the moment though you're
gonna put roadblocks in there because
the rest of your life you'll have
moments of feeling less than I wrote two
dissertations one of which is now
required reading in on the topic that I
wrote on I've written one best-selling
book followed by a number one
best-selling book after that and I sat
down to write a new book recently and
the first 30 pages I wrote I just looked
at it and said I'm a loser and I don't
know what I'm doing
what an absolute scam I'm running here I
beat myself up for a long time
why do I tell you that you're gonna have
seasons of less than for the rest of
your life it's just called life and
you're gonna have to have some
roadblocks until you get control of the
addiction okay correct Fair
share
here's the uh here's the last one I'll
wrap it up with four
this is a huge start because you you
have admitted this in front of what will
be millions of people okay
yes
shame eats secrets for breakfast it's
one of my favorite brene Brown quotes
and shame is the thing that keeps you
walking around thinking you're less than
that you're broken deficient that you
suck that you're a loser you're gross
okay
correct the one antidote to shame that I
think trumps every other antidote
is saying out loud here's who I am to
other people
and so whether you find an essay Group
which I know they have in Vegas uh
sexual sexaholics Anonymous which is a
group of men and women who get together
and speak openly here's what I've been
struggling with
and when you sit in a circle of 15 or 20
men or women some are 30 years older
than you some are 10 years younger than
you and you say I masturbate 30 times a
day and I can't stop
you'll see a room full of people all nod
and go yeah we've been there man
and suddenly your body completely
relaxes because you're not all alone
you're not the psychopath loser that you
think you are okay
correct you have to this isn't a I want
to strongly recommend you have to have
other people in your life that you are
regularly telling the truth to okay
exactly
is that fair that's very fair let me let
me be even clearer you cannot do this by
yourself this ends in ashes if you don't
exactly you were really really close if
you haven't already you are razor thin
close to meetups
exactly okay
correct Fair
yes and you've probably gotten pretty
dang close already
absolutely okay
take another breath and exhale real
quick
here's my promise to you I'll walk
alongside you the whole way okay
thank you so much John
tell me how you feel what does your body
feel right now
after hearing that and taking that all
in it I kind of feel like a big uh I
would say like a rock was taken off my
back that's been hunching me over for a
long time you know it feels like you
know
that knowing what you said it opens my
mind that you know there is that I'm not
alone there's a big there's always
a brighter future and that that there's
nothing that's ever impossible but it
takes some effort and it takes some work
on you know on the victim's part you
know well it's on the victim's part and
you played a role in it right exactly
and you were a kid
so now we're doing adult things I don't
hold children responsible almost almost
never because they're kids okay you're
an adult sometimes afterwards we have to
respond to kids actions right but
they're children
um you're gonna you're gonna have to
make adult decisions now so here's where
you found yourself and now we gotta we
gotta take
um a right turn maybe Vegas isn't the
right Community for you
maybe I don't know
um maybe your group of friends isn't the
right group of friends
but before this day is over every app is
off your phone
or you've just gone down to a t or
T-Mobile or Cricket or whoever you use
and you're getting a flip phone that you
can't access
before this day is over you've looked up
and contacted and made it and put on
your calendar that you're going to the
next essay meeting there's probably one
tonight this evening in your local
community I guarantee you there's one
tomorrow morning
and we're gonna go
and we're going to tell the truth
in your counselor your previous
counselor sucked sorry find another one
it's not an excuse to not do the work
and let me be real real clear this is
gonna be hard
and you're gonna have days where you
fail miserably okay cool Shake It Off
we're on to the next
because we're gonna practice this new
identity as we move forward we're gonna
practice it I'm just kind of I'm the
kind of guy who I'm the kind of guy who
I'm the kind of guy who and then one day
you're gonna meet somebody and you have
to sit down to explain to them dude I
was a full-blown addict
you jerked off 30 times a day yep yeah I
had a problem
and you're gonna feel nervous they may
leave you but we're gonna be honest
we're gonna be honest we're gonna be
honest
because you're worth being honest hang
on the line Joseph I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change your future
um I want you to read it and cover to
cover and then shoot me a direct message
and let me know what you think and
anytime you want to call and be on the
show I'm here for you okay I'm grateful
for your for your bravery and your
honesty
there are brighter days ahead my brother
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the hell the housing market is
right now and how powerless home buyers
feel mix that with the stress of moving
and life change and job change and
you've got a tornado of anxiety fueling
one of the biggest purchases you'll ever
make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the homebuyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org equal housinglender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back
um hey John yes ma'am I am calling a bit
of an audible here
I was on time today I bathed
I did all the things yes
and oh is this his highlighted thing yes
so we didn't schedule a call for this
segment because I found something
actually something was sent to me by one
of our other associate producers from
Tick Tock that I wanted to talk about
this is my favorite subject Tech talk
well it's not about Tick Tock but so
there's a woman on tick knock on Tick
Tock good Lord what are these ask doc
Courtney she is a trauma therapist okay
and she posts um she had posted recently
some little sticky notes that just had
quotes that her young clients had said
to her over the past couple of weeks and
I wanted to read these to you just so
you know she got permission to post
these there's no names or anything but
I'm going to read you what they said and
then how old the person was and then I
want you to respond to him yep for that
let's do it all right this will be
awesome if the trauma therapist says
things that I've said exactly this is
like the world's saddest lightning round
just to let you know all right the first
one this is from a six-year-old if I ran
away my parents wouldn't know they don't
say good night anymore
oh my gosh
so children
have one love language in its presence
not presents like wrapped up with a bow
on top but presents
p-r-e-s-e-n-c-e and bedtime it I think
is one of the most critical times
because the whirling dervish energy
stops if you knew one thing parents
have dinner with your kids the research
is really clear on that the second thing
is have a bedtime routine where you get
to touch your kid on the face look him
in the eye and say I love you hope
you've had a great day what's your best
thing to happen what's the hardest thing
to happen and I'll be here in the
morning golly
all right the next one is from a 16 year
old
being alone in my room is okay it
doesn't mean I'm suicidal or sad
man
yeah as kids get older
um this is hard man so as when kids are
younger parents often use their kids and
their questions and their ability to
give wise answers to these little kids
and they're driving them all over the
community as a way to fuel their
self-esteem I am who I am because I do
all these things for this kid and this
kid relies and needs me
the only kid turns 15 16 or 17 they
start developing autonomy I just need
some space I need some time to think I
need to wrestle with the world I got to
do homework I don't have time to talk to
you I don't have time to I don't want to
do gymnastics anymore just so you feel
better about yourself and then parents
begin knocking on the door what about me
what about me what about me
come out of your room what are you doing
in there why are you checking on your
kid is very important letting you know
your kid know they're loved is important
but also giving them some time
to have their own space and moms and
dads if you feel oh man you're getting
me fired up if you feel like well who am
I then that's a you problem not a kid
problem for your 16 year old to solve
ugh okay go ahead
as a parent of a 16 year old I don't
like that one
all right this is from another 16 year
old my mom says in a minute and hours go
by this is why I yell this is why I yell
in demand she forgets me
dude guilty is charged on this one
guilty is charged
parents and you say in a minute that
means 60 seconds to your child
unless you lie to them and one minute
means 14 minutes or 30 minutes or when I
get done looking at this website or I
get done scrolling Instagram or
Pinterest for a while
say in 10 minutes say in 15 minutes
and when your kid starts yelling and
demanding your attention remember
behavior is a language
don't ask yourself why is that kid
causing such a ruckus
ask yourself what is that my kid trying
to tell me oh
they don't know how to say hey Dad
you're a liar hey Mom you're a liar they
do know how to say look at me over here
oh you won't look at me I'll smash this
vase I'll do something because I just
need to know that you love me okay
all right I'm called out on that one
from a 15 year old lying to me when I
ask if you are okay makes me not trust
myself I am connected to you yep that
goes back to one of the things I've said
over and over on this show
um
if you're not okay the one of the
greatest gifts you can give your kids is
to be honest with them because if you
don't they're gonna think they're crazy
because they feel you not being okay and
they're gonna wonder what is wrong with
them that mom lies to me the death
doesn't tell me the truth they're going
to wonder what is it about Mom that I'm
doing to make her not feel okay so if
you're not okay if you have a bad day at
work you got a hard day at work your
boss laid into you you've got troubles
in your marriage you got Financial
challenges obviously don't tell the kid
we're gonna lose the house
but do let them know yeah Mom's under a
lot of stress
and sometimes I don't do a good job
letting you know that I love you and
this my stress isn't your fault
but I'm so grateful for you right being
honest with your kid don't ever say the
words nothing honey it's fine because
that's a lie it's a lie and it's a lie
that's gonna make your kids feel crazy
all right from a seven-year-old I feel
like a bad kid when I make a mistake
usually because my parents think I did
it on purpose
they don't think you did it on purpose
here's what parents think they think
that kids are their report card
that kids are their scorecard and when
kids mess up it's a reflection of me
you left the milk out which somehow ties
back to me being a bad parent not being
you you being 12 and you don't you're
off in la la land or you didn't get
enough sleep or I'll let you eat seven
hamburgers yesterday nothing to do with
that has to do with you're my scorecard
you're my walking report card
and every mistake you make as a 7 9 12
17 year old reflects on me and that's
bullcrap parents stop
kids make mistakes why because they're
kids
we teach them we hold them accountable
but they're kids they're kids man jeez
sorry I can hear you breathing these are
getting fired up man
all right um this is from a
nine-year-old my mom is too busy she
says but she texts her friends all day
why not tell the truth she's just
avoiding me
nine-year-olds ten-year-olds
six-year-olds 15 year olds 15 year olds
do
little kids don't know how to ask hey
Mom why are you avoiding me they just
internalize it and they Wonder
what's so much why does she love that
little shiny box more than me
what is so annoying about me
what is that little shiny box have that
I don't have
and those kids will spend the rest of
their life making up stories about it or
trying to solve it either through
burning your house down or making
Straight A's and marrying the perfect
person
because they're trying to win your love
any Mom isn't trying to avoid you but
that's a story a nine-year-old makes up
so they can sleep at night because Mom's
spending more time with the little
digital box than she is with her kid
put your phones down parents and this is
me this is the pot talking to Kettle
here man geez Louise these are
convicting Kelly thanks for ruining my
day I was already having a not great
parenting morning so thanks for kicking
me while I'm down sure all right uh 10
year old taking away all that I love
doesn't motivate me it makes me feel
hopeless yes okay listen
I probably need to do a whole segment on
the show on this
um
when you punish a kid
with I can do what I want because I got
bigger muscles than you or I've got more
power than you you did this so I'm
taking away this you did this so I'm not
taking you to the zoo anymore you did
this so no video games for you
the kid doesn't get the correlation they
then start acting so that they don't
lose relational Capital with Mom and Dad
not actually they don't actually learn
and adapt to the new behaviors that we
want
that's why it's so important to teach
kids that they get to choose
so in my house there's Seasons when if
my son gets in trouble and he can't I
don't know but let's pretend we had an
Xbox we don't have one of those but if
we had an Xbox
and he makes a bad grade I can go in and
say you got a bad grade so I'm taking
the Xbox which is me saying I've got
bigger muscles and I've got power and
you your life will be about what I want
no
I will say hey in this house we have
this standard of academic Excellence
nothing is more important than your
grades and your character right now and
here's the standard I've set you can
choose to meet it or not cool your
choice and so if you don't need it
you're just choosing to not play Xbox
for the next six weeks that's cool
that's your choice
and my son is going to learn that he has
responsibilities and choices in his life
and the consequences are things that he
chooses you can choose to not drive the
speed limit and you're choosing to get
tickets you're choosing to go to jail
you're choosing to kill somebody
crossing a streak that's your choice and
there's consequences and accountability
on the back end of it not you can't you
see what I'm saying golly dude don't
flex on your kids they're kids
teach them how to make choices
sorry
all right
Kelly this is a 13 year old telling me
that you're disappointed in me kills me
I didn't do what I did to hurt you I was
just learning
oh boy
you answer this one Kelly
no thank you
um parents your 13 year old should not
have the power
to regulate your emotions because you're
an adult and they're a child
I don't give my kids the power to make
me mad I sometimes choose to be angry
and I use that kind of language my kids
don't have the power to frustrate me I
can choose to be frustrated and I let
them know I'm choosing to be frustrated
right now because I've asked you four
times to do X Y and Z and you've chosen
not to I'm choosing to be frustrated
but I don't tell them if you do that I'm
gonna get mad or if you do something I'm
going to be really disappointed in you
you don't have that kind of strength or
power because I'm an adult and you're a
child
parents when kids feel like they are
responsible for the emotional regulation
of the adults in their life they crumble
under the weight because they can't
carry it because they're kids
so if you find yourself angry you find
yourself frustrated you find yourself
lashing out you find yourself all raged
out and mad at your kids that's a you
problem not them
you have to ask yourself what is it
about a nine-year-old that is making me
lose control what is it a foot about a
16 year old that's making me rage out
that's a you question
not a 16 year old kid question
because here's my promise that 16 year
old gets compliant real fast you're
still going to have that rage you're
just going to direct it at your boss at
your partner you're going to direct it
at the mail man you're gonna direct it
at politics because
that's a rage problem that you have your
kid's just an easy target
you solve you quit asking your kids to
carry you uh your emotions ugh okay
there we go next one uh 13 year old hey
I can just feel people like
unsubscribing as we go down like I'm out
I'm out I'm out no I don't think so
because I think that as parents we all
see ourselves in some of these uh from a
13 year old when I annoy my mom it's
because I want her attention I don't get
it any other way
yeah
um it goes back to the first the first
one up here
um the the number one way kids absorb
love is through presence
not always attention but presence
mom is here with us in the room she's
not sitting there like an organic lump
of matter but she's two thousand miles
away on Pinterest or Dad is sitting
there on the chair with his feet propped
up watching TV he's not with us
presence is a huge deal and kids will go
to the ends of the Earth it was when a
trauma psychologist it was a buddy of
mine told me hey dude you know Straight
A's is a trauma response too sometimes
and I was like uh say what and he's like
yeah dude kids who don't get adult
attention will set something on fire
they'll hit somebody in the face they
will become emotionally dysregulated or
they'll be the best player on the
baseball team
they'll give up every weekend of their
life chasing a silly little ball
traveling all over God knows where
spending tens and tens of thousands of
dollars of their parents money just so
Mom and Dad will look at them and say
we're proud of you
kids will give it all up
including their freedom they will they
will take punishment if you'll just show
them that you're present with them and
sometimes it takes a kid hitting
somebody or burning something down or
dropping something for parents to snap
out of their La La Land and just be
present
be present man
my parents are better off divorcing I
feel like I'm having I'm just talking to
myself
I'm just talking really frustrated to
this camera here I'm just talking to
myself because good gosh almost all
these are just calling me out here
ah all right this is an eight-year-old
my parents are better off just divorcing
they stay together for my siblings and I
when an eight-year-old says that here's
what an eight-year-old says I my body
can't handle the tension in my home
anymore
I need it to stop
it's the same as when somebody says they
are considering Dying by Suicide I've
never met one that really wants to be
dead
I've met almost all of them really want
to stop hurting
and so I can almost guarantee you this
eight-year-old doesn't want divorced
parents
his body is craving peace
and there's some real incredible
literature that suggests a couple who
chooses and I use that word
intentionally a couple who chooses to
have a good marriage they make that
decision every day every week every
month every year
they live longer their health is better
the their legacy changes their kids
lives are better and
adults who choose miserable marriages I
just fell out of luck shut up parents
who choose
adults who choose bad marriages
um they have shorter lives their kids
are a mess and on and on and on
and so I think I really believe this I
think almost every marriage is
salvageable
almost everyone barring a couple of
outside of the bell curve issues
if you refuse to be adults and choose to
have a joyful marriage choose to get
help for your challenges choose to learn
some new skills on how to communicate
together choose these things
then yeah that year old's probably right
because then you're choosing to make
your kids miserable and you're choosing
to die early and why would you choose
that right but date your old man I wish
my parents are just divorce now what
he's saying is
I wish the fight he would stop I wish
the tension in that home would stop I
wish I could sleep without having to
cover my face up with my pillow and
block my ears that's what that
eight-year-old saying and that breaks my
heart man
all right uh 10 years old I love my mom
and dad even when they yell at me I
always love them I wish they I wish I
knew that they loved me as much
[Music]
don't yell at your kids
parents don't yell at your kids
yelling at your kids is trauma it it
disregulates them
it overwhelms their response system
don't yell at your kids because this kid
said it perfectly they still love you
and they're Tethered to you they can't
move
when you're in a bar and you're throwing
punches at somebody they can run out the
door
when you're a 10 year old and your dad
is yelling at you they got nowhere to go
and their bodies can't absorb it
parents don't yell at your kids
hey let's do some more Kelly gosh last
one
hey we'll do one more but you gotta
promise the next time it's gonna be all
just joyful things yes it'll be puppy
dogs and rainbows I promise well puppies
poop everywhere well actually this one's
about the dog so we probably shouldn't
use puppy dogs let's do it let's do it
this is from a seven-year-old
my dog gets more attention dad says it's
because the dog can't talk so I stopped
talking
[Music]
I don't think I even need to respond to
that
this father isn't worthy of that
seven-year-old's love
[Music]
No One's Gonna Make My
uh yeah I'm gonna leave it that I'm out
we'll be right back
bologna here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor better help let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
we are back and um
man I'd like to thank Kelly for that
little bit of that ray of sunshine she
just put into all of our lives here
no actually I'm glad you did that uh I I
think
I think I've mentioned this on the show
I remember when my kid was he was in
sixth grade my son was his last year
when the um Rush Invasion kicked off and
I took him up to our room
um to the guest room and said I just sat
him down and said hey this is a this is
a grown-up conversation we're gonna have
this is a
um two guys having a grown-up
conversation he said yes sir I hear you
I said tell me what you know about
um The Rush Invasion and whoa
him and his buddies were already talking
about what they'll do if they get
drafted about how long this is going to
take how close we are to world war three
they knew a lot
and we often forget just how incredibly
articulate and absorbent our children
are
five six seven five and six and seven
the younger ones feel it they feel the
energy five and six and sevens and they
start telling stories
and so don't ever think that your kids
don't know what's going on they may not
know the details of the particulars but
they absorb every second of it and so
much of their behavior is trying to
discharge
their responsibility to keep the house
together and it's just it's a mess man
be honest with your kids
because they know they know
all right let's go out to Bridget in
Lancaster what's up Bridget
hey how you doing Dr John party and what
about you oh working awesome you should
you should get a job where you can party
at it
I would love a job where I could party
at work yeah podcaster dude I'm running
a scam here it's so good so good all
right so what's up
all right so
um
my boyfriend and I we live together and
um he's wonderful to me never treats me
badly
um but there's hold on hold on you're
gonna watch us on YouTube and you're
gonna see me just start laughing then
anytime somebody calls and says I'm in
love and they're so great then there's a
butt and then they end up not being so
great is that where we're headed well
all right tell me about him so it's more
of a situation where we're kind of we're
not on the same page about certain
things that to me are important uh so
basically he has this obsession with
buying clothes and shoes and all of
these things but he has no intentions of
like saving money for the future he's
thinking about the now and it drives me
crazy
um to kind of speak on that so he is
ADHD and he's very impulsive me too I
don't care okay go ahead
no so
so very impulsive
how I can work with him a little bit
more on these things and it's his money
so obviously I'm not going to get
involved in like why are you spending
money so on and so forth
um but it's something that's frustrating
for me because you know we have rings or
you know ready to get married
but I don't want to do that if I have to
constantly be concerned that he's not
planning for the Future Okay
um so so I need to be a better
girlfriend but he needs to be a better
boyfriend in the sense of listening to
me and and understanding where I'm
coming from just as I try to do for him
okay
um I'm gonna disagree with you on a
couple of things is that cool okay yeah
absolutely
um or I'll just say it this way you
can't fix him
you can't change him there's not a thing
that you haven't done that makes him go
oh you're right I spend money like an
idiot or I'm trying to present myself to
the world as a bro dude because I got
dope shoes and shirts and jackets like
um
that's not your responsibility one and
two you can't do anything about it
and you're entering into a marriage here
right y'all are really close you got
Rings you got all the stuff
it's so good you're figuring this out
now
okay there's one person on planet Earth
you can control that's you yeah
absolutely and you can control your
thoughts and your actions
my guess is you spent a ton of energy
wondering what you can say what you can
do how you can present all those things
to him
and what you haven't done is spent a lot
of energy on saying do I want to be
married to this for the rest of my life
right you haven't spent a lot of energy
setting up boundaries or you may have
never had the conversation that said
your spending scares me to death
and I am not interested in connecting
myself to a hot air balloon that hasn't
checked the gas tanks just want to keep
seeing how high we can go
and here's but hey Bridget you know this
so let me ask you a hard question
why do you think so little of yourself
like who told you that
nobody probably me no no no no no no you
I mean you you said it you just need to
be a better girlfriend no
he used to be a grown man
you know what I mean that's true
yeah I feel like you know anytime I try
to have the money talk uh with him it
kind of goes south because he's working
on the baby stuff this has nothing to do
with money has nothing to do with money
this has to do with a guy that is still
a child
he thinks of himself like a child he
acts like a child and yeah he in his
defense
he thinks so little of himself
that he is continually searching for the
right pair of shoes and the right jacket
that's going to finally make him feel
whole and he will never find it
ever
he'll even lie to himself and say these
shoes are an investment
he'll lie to himself and say I'll be
able to resale this jacket
yeah he does
you know what I mean and that's him
trying to that's a prop up of a prop up
of a proper
now I've got too many shoes
I got way too many t-shirts so much so
that my wife has implemented some closet
rules she didn't tell me you need to
stop buying t-shirts she said in the
closet that we share it will have this
many clothing items in it on this side
and I'm just gonna randomly take the
other ones off that's her boundary right
and so ta-da
she's not owning the fact that like I I
can't John you buy too many t-shirts
she's not gonna that's that's my problem
to bear
I like buying band T-shirts I buy them
obsessively right too many
um but she says this is how he's gonna
be in the closet because I can't live
like this and here was the conversation
that convicted me
I feel overwhelmed when I walk into our
closet and I can't I can't we there's
there's I can't breathe there's too much
it's too crammed full
it's hard for me to do your laundry when
I can't fit the shirts up there and by
the way they all look the same they're
all just dumb black t-shirts with some
stupid band on right
here's what she did though
she didn't come in after me about my
behavior
she came and said she owned it she used
the word I this is how I feel
this is what your actions are doing to
me and I can't control your actions but
I can control my behavior and my
thoughts
and so my actions are going to be I'm
going to take the things out that make
me feel not well
right
and that means I'll give you one you can
be a better girlfriend you can be more
honest and you haven't been honest with
them
you can be way more clear
and you can be much more firm in your
boundaries
is that fair definitely that's that's
totally fair that's something that I I
struggle with because I think my
reactions to the actions that he takes
it's more of like a I get irritated and
respond to him in a negative way instead
of just being assertive and saying hey
this is this is what the plan is here
this is what we need to start and that's
that's how I know somebody told you that
because somewhere along the way you
picked up the narrative that your
feelings don't matter
or your feelings are stupid or you need
to put them in a drawer and your life
was about peacekeeping other making sure
everybody else is okay and what's
happening as you're entering into a
marriage is you realize I'm trying to
make him feel okay and your body is
screaming at you we're not safe
because this guy won't think past next
Tuesday when the shoes are released yeah
okay exactly right and you have you're
at a you're at a Crossroads here you can
do what millions and millions and
millions of men and women have done
which is take their bodies alarms and
shut them off you can have another drink
and another drink and another let's go
out well and I'm gonna shut them off you
can watch another Netflix series and
another series and buy another bed
spread and another runner for the living
room because that's going to be the one
that solves it
or
you can start for the first time looking
in the mirror and saying dude I'm
freaking Bridgette my feelings matter
when I'm not safe I'm not going to enter
into relationships or spaces where I'm
not safe
and I'm gonna for the people I love I'm
gonna be honest with them about my
feelings of being not safe
yeah I do need to start doing that
that's that's absolutely correct I'm
I've never really
been good at communicating that's
something all my life I've just been
really bad so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna start practicing we're gonna
start practicing it's not a character
flaw okay you haven't had Avenues to
practice if you just walked into a
basketball gym and you'd never picked up
a ball and you started shooting it you
look like a weirdo it wouldn't be fair
to criticize you you've never done it
before
like we're gonna get you some coaching
and then we're going to teach you how to
shoot and then you got to practice
shooting free throws a lot and then in
short order you're going to catch on
okay and your shop may always not be
pretty but you'll be able to get the
ball through the net and that's what
we're going for here you're gonna start
practicing communication and that's how
I would start the conversation with him
hey I've not told you the truth
like we're thinking about getting
married and I haven't been fully honest
with you
so I'm gonna start saying my needs out
loud I'm gonna practice doing it and I'm
going to make a bunch of apologies I'm
gonna be nervous so don't freak out but
I'm gonna start speaking up my part of
my mind because I'm equal part in this
relationship too and I haven't been
honest with you the way you spend money
scares me to death
I'm not going to enter into a marriage
that is financially irresponsible from
day one
because money is one of the top things
that breaks marriages up but I'm not
going to enter into the marriage already
knowing that we're driving a heading
straight into the ditch
so here's what I'm going to do for You
Bridget I'm going to send you
um I work here at Ramsey Solutions I'm
going to send you FPU for free for a
year
that's all the lessons all the stuff and
I want you all to watch them together
I'm also going to send you the every
dollar app
which is a budgeting tool
um I'm going to send it to you for free
for a year okay the premium one that
looks hooks up with your bank it's the
one we all use okay and here's what that
is it's a finance tool it is it's a
budgeting tool it is
but it's a marriage saver it's a
relationship saver because it forces
people to sit down or it's gonna be a
relationship Ender too let's be honest
it forces you to sit down across a table
and say
do our actions line up with our values
am I safe in this relationship are we
being who we say we're being and if you
want to find out who somebody is look at
their calendar and look at their budget
look at their bank statement
so we're gonna this is gonna bring
everybody to the table we're gonna watch
these videos together as a couple and
you're gonna say this is important to me
and this matters and if my feeling safe
isn't more important than the latest Air
Jordan release that's cool you're a
grown-up you get to do that I'm out
I'm out
[Music]
we're gonna sell the house and I'm gonna
go and I love you I'll probably always
love you
but just because I love you doesn't mean
I gotta be married to you just because
I've liked being in a relationship we've
had some good times doesn't mean I'm
gonna hitch my wagon
to a wagon that's
um there's no bolts on the wheels things
gonna fall off at some point
hey you caught this thing early Bridget
and I'm proud of you you got a hard road
ahead of you some hard practicing some
hard conversations some some new skills
to learn
think you can do and I think you can
come around
he just has to think you're more
valuable than a new shirt some new shoes
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show man
what a what a bundle of joy this
episode's been
oh next next episode we're just gonna
walk through the various new Doodles
that uh people have created in their
doodle Laboratories actually we're not I
think those are sad too we're gonna
we're just gonna show pictures of Basset
Hounds because I think they're the best
uh but today's song of the day is from
the great Bob Dylan and the song is
Forever Young and it goes like this
may God bless and keep you always and
may your wishes all come true and may
you always do for others and let others
do for you and may you build a ladder to
the stars and climb on every rung and
may you stay forever young
may you grow up to be righteous may you
grow up to be true may you always know
the truth and see the light surrounding
you this is a song to those little kids
may you always be courageous stand
upright and be strong may you stay
forever
yeah
go get him I love you guys we'll see you
soon
[Music]